when you teach about American history
the hardest thing is to bring it alive
we always think about it as the past but
sometimes when you see a book or a
document or an artifact it makes it come
alive in a way that you hadn't thought
about before we haven't a delightful of
this wonderful addition to the Kirby
Center here at Hillsdale College an
extremely rare and powerful letter it
was the gift of the family of Mark Levin
who previously gave us original copy of
the Federalist Papers has now given us
something perhaps even more historically
significant and it's letter written by a
forgotten patron named Joseph Warren
Joseph Warren was in charge of the
defense of Boston Massachusetts prior to
the outbreak of the American Revolution
Joseph Warren was the man who sent Paul
Revere on a ride on the night of April
18th to warn the countryside that the
British were coming
he warned John Hancock and Samuel Adams
who fled and of course the British did
come and that led to skirmishes at
Lexington and Concord the Americans are
the colonists the rebels chased the
British back to Boston at this time
Joseph Warren is in charge of the
defense of Boston he's the head of the
Committee of Safety and the letter we
received he writes on June 4th and he
writes it to the colony of New York
desperately asking for ammunition and
gunpowder in less than two weeks later
there we a battle the battle we know is
Bunker Hill and after the battle the
British not only immediately kill him
because they know who he is but they
desecrate his body and his body is later
identified by Paul Revere Joseph Warren
was the first great martyr and the great
hero of the American Revolution before
George Washington and this is a letter
of one of its kind in beautiful
condition very valuable very powerful
and this is a real letter written by a
real man in a real difficult situation
and we know in hindsight that he's gonna
be killed and the Americans will lose
that battle to the British and we also
know which they didn't know at the time
that it was the first battle of the
American Revolution that's extremely
powerful and evoking the best in the
highest the excellence of these
individuals that we honor and we speak
of as our founding
others and there were real people who
sacrificed and did great things who we
ought to remember